[MUSIC]
Thank you, so about two years ago today,
after I'd first moved out to the US,
I went up to Tahoe with
a group of GSB classmates.
And the GSB really started our
immense carry-on with the holiday.
But when we were up there, I remember
walking through the beautiful mountain
air overlooking the lake, when suddenly
the silence and the bird song were
shattered by someone shouting, you are
such an asshole, you can say that here!
I was a little bit shocked.
Someone was shouting at me, why?
Because I had just said that I voted for
Brexit.
Now I have to say I felt pretty taken
aback by someone that I'd really
only just met, who was from Boston and
had really zero affiliation with
the UK at all getting angry at me for
how I voted in the Brexit referendum.
That it made me realize that Brexit
is a controversial topic and
engenders a lot of negative
stereotypes and negative emotions.
And this guy had made an assumption about
me that really was totally incorrect and
misconstrued why I voted for Brexit.
And so I want to use this opportunity
today to tell you about why I did vote
for Brexit.
I voted for Brexit because I want
Britain to be more open, more global.
I've not voted for Brexit because I
want Britain to close in on itself.
And I'm worried that all the bright,
intelligent people here at Stanford and
across the rest of the world will be
scared about going, and living, and
working, and
investing in the UK because of those
negative stereotypes about Brexit.
I look forward to a post-Brexit
Britain that's more open, more global,
and more inclusive, than it was before.
And I want you guys all to be
excited about that, as well.
So let me start off by putting
the EU in an American context.
In my mind, the European Union
can be split into two parts,
a political union and an economic union.
So if we apply this to the Americas,
if we apply an economic union, imagine
a federation of all 23 countries in
the whole of the Americas from Canada
all the way through to Argentina.
Trade would be free and tariff-free.
Argentinian steaks could be enjoyed
in Anchorage in the same way
that the Alaskan oil and
gas could be traded in Buenos Aires.
People would also be able to move freely,
traveling wherever they liked to live,
to work, to study without discrimination.
How many of you in this room,
and I want to see some hands,
how many of you in this room would vote
for such a system in the Americas?
So a few of you,
now think about the political union.
Under the political union, we take a new
parliament and paste it, say, in Peru.
And this would supersede the US House and
Senate and would start to make the
majority of the rules that govern the US.
Now for the Americans of you in the room,
I'm sure you all love and
you all respect the Supreme Court, but
we're going to replace that, as well.
We're going to put a new court,
say, in Belize.
And this court is going to be staffed with
judges from across the Americas and will
make the majority of the legal decisions
that mattered to the United States.
Now how many of you would vote for
that system?
So I don't see any hands.
And that, for me,
is what the European Union is about.
Now people in this room, I'm sure you
like Mexicans, you like the Canadians,
especially if they look like
Justin Trudeau or Rachel McAdams.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
you do not want the good people of
Ottawa to be telling you what to do.
You don't want the good people of Ottawa
to be telling you how many hours you
should be allowed to work in a given day,
whether your prisoners should
be allowed to vote or not, and,
most bizarrely of all, the size and
shape that your bananas should be.
Now those are all things that the EU does.
And so for me,
Britain leaving the European union is
about leaving that political union.
Taking back those decisions to the UK is
not about leaving the economic union.
I think leaving the economic union of
the European Union would be bad for
both Britain and for
the rest of the world.
It's going to make people poorer if
Germans can't sell their cars into
the UK and we can't sell our scotch
whiskey into the rest of Europe.
But by leaving the political union,
I hope that we can expand our trade
beyond just the European boundaries and
embrace more global trade.
At the moment, global trade deals have
to be negotiated at a European level.
Britain is not free to go
negotiate trade deals on its own.
And that results in complications.
Within Europe, there's lots of different
countries with lots of different economies
and different motives and interests.
And those trade deals, as a consequence,
take a long time to negotiate.
The most recent one was with Canada.
And that took seven years for
the European Union to negotiate that deal.
My hope is that Britain can embrace the
trading networks that we historically had.
Britain has a great commonwealth and, for
a long time, traded around the world.
In the 1960s and
70s, when Britain first applied to
join the European Economic Community,
which is the precursor of the EU,
it was actually vetoed.
Us joining was vetoed by the French.
And the French reason was precisely
because they believed that Britain's
trading networks were to too far-flung,
distant, and diverse lands.
So I believe that by leaving the European
Union, Britain can re-embrace and
reestablish those historical trading
networks, embracing the world,
not closing in on itself.
Now embracing the world does
not just mean economically.
It also means embracing
the world's people.
When I moved to the US two years ago,
it was the first experience I'd ever had
of being an immigrant to another country.
And I realized quickly how difficult and
how many difficult decisions you end up
being forced to make when
you move to somewhere else.
The hardest one for me involved my
girlfriend at the time, called Sophie.
Now Sophie and I had gone out for
two and a half years.
And I loved her very much.
But when I got the phone call from
Derrick saying that I got into Stanford,
the six months following that, the elation
of getting into Stanford, and coming and
living in California, and meeting all you
amazing people, that elation slowly turned
to despair as we realized that the US visa
rules meant it'd be almost impossible for
Sophie to move out with me.
Now I ended up, obviously,
coming, and Sophie stayed behind.
And unfortunately, the 12-hour flight and
the 8-hour time difference was too
much for our relationship to bear.
That struck me as being incredibly
unfair that bright, young,
ambitious people could not come and
work in the US and
could not come and
contribute to the economy here.
But unfortunately,
the same is true of the UK and for
Americans wanting to go and
work and live in the UK.
You would find it extremely difficult
when Britain is part of your,
to go and move and work there.
And the reason is is that you would be
behind the queue of people from Poland,
from France, from Italy that are all
entitled to come, and work, and
live in the UK.
By having open borders to the whole
of Europe, you build walls for
the rest of the world.
And I want those walls to come down.
Britain should be open to accepting
the Ben's and Sophie's of China, of USA,
of India, of Africa and accepting as many
bright and brilliant people as we can.
We should not just be restricted
to the Benjamin's, Bonjaman's,
and Benzino's of Europe.
So for me, opening up to the world
is really what Brexit is about.
It's not about closing in.
And if I go back to that time in Tahoe,
I wish I hadn't been so taken aback.
There are fundamental misconceptions and
stereotypes
that are applied to people that voted for
Brexit, but Brexit is going to happen.
And it's time that people that voted for
Brexit to stop feeling demonized for
the way they voted and start coming out
and presenting a positive image for
Brexit and for post-Brexit Britain.
For my part, Brexit for
me was about opening Britain up
to the world, not closing us in.
I'm excited about the future
of post-Brexit Britain
as a hub of globalization, accepting
brilliant people from around the world.
And I hope some of you will come join us,
thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]